On April 16th, 1999, the Raleigh Ripper was
finally brought to justice, after a reign
of terror across the state of North Carolina
that left fourteen women dead.
The killer’s true identity had been Kevin
Gruber, a local gas station attendant originally
from West Virginia, who was arrested at work
in the early hours of the morning.
His face was plastered all over the media
when he was cuffed and dragged in to be questioned
and processed.
Like many serial killers, the most frightening
thing about Kevin was the fact that he just
seemed so...normal.
The idea that a person like this could have
committed the atrocities of the Raleigh Ripper
raised a frightening question we all need
to contend with.
What turns a person into a monster?
This question was particularly prescient for
Dr. James Whitington, a criminal psychologist
tasked with conducting the first official
psychological evaluation on Gruber.
Ever since the true identity of the killer
had come to light, the case had held a particular
fascination for him.
Mainly because Gruber The Man and Gruber The
Killer seemed to almost be two entirely separate
people.
According to all evidence, The Raleigh Ripper
was an insidious, methodical criminal genius.
He’d stalked some of his victims - all women
who lived alone - for weeks before striking,
conducting detailed surveillance of their
homes that allowed him to isolate them, bypass
their security systems, and remove any means
of getting help.
He blocked doors, cut phone lines, and always
selected vulnerable targets.
Despite being a seasoned criminal psychologist,
the actual details of Gruber’s crimes had
kept Whitington awake at night.
He had a wife and a young son at home, and
the thought of a man like Gruber prowling
out there made him fear for both of them.
This was no thrill killer - He was a sadistic
torturer, who seemed to delight in the pain
and terror of his prey.
He’d chosen victims he could take his time
with.
Infiltrated their homes like a gust of cold
air through an open window and slipped out
through darkness like a shadow.
Perfectly controlled crime scenes.
No stray evidence.
Nothing but death left behind.
For months, he’d run circles around the
police.
Thousands of people who fit the Raleigh Ripper
profile were interviewed.
Sting operations were conducted.
Communities formed neighborhood watches to
keep each other safe from the killer’s next
move.
And none of it did any good.
From seasoned detectives to legions of beat
cops, nobody could get the jump on Kevin Gruber.
The fact he was even caught came out of pure
chance: A local hiker, Mike Fletcher, just
so happened to hear the screaming coming from
a nearby home in the woods and made the heroic
decision to run in and intervene.
When he walked in on Gruber committing the
attack, the killer panicked, and fled through
an open window.
In his haste, he’d left a partial print
on the window frame.
That, combined with Mike’s description of
the assailant, was enough to finally link
Kevin to the fourteen murders of the Raleigh
Ripper.
The problem, from Dr. Whitington’s perspective,
was that, by all accounts, Kevin Gruber seemed
to be an idiot.
This was no suave, charismatic Ted Bundy type.
In all the prior photos and interviews, Kevin
had that deer-in-the-headlights look of a
man who’s just in way over his head.
Dr. Whitington had also pored over Kevin’s
school records.
The only thing he seemed to excel at was being
mediocre.
He even got held back a year in fifth grade.
Since graduating high school, he’d been
kicked out by his parents for freeloading,
and hadn’t been able to consistently hold
down a job for more than eight months.
His only prior criminal convictions had been
one drunk and disorderly conduct charge, and
possession of an ounce of pot back in 1991,
for which he got a suspended sentence due
to being a minor at the time.
It just didn’t make sense to Dr. Whitington
that this man and the diabolically brilliant
Raleigh Ripper were the same person, despite
all the incontrovertible evidence proving
it so.
Despite his reservations, he needed to meet
this man, and find out why and how he committed
all these horrific murders, despite being
such an unremarkable individual.
Sitting across from Gruber in the secure interview
chamber, Whitington was once again struck
with how incredibly disappointing he was.
Thin and wiry, with glazed-over eyes, messy
hair, and a pathetic tuft of weak stubble
on his chin.
He looked more like Shaggy from Scooby-Doo
than a cold-blooded killer.
His answers to most of Dr. Whitington’s
questions were also insubstantial - with him
often losing his train of thought, or even
needing to ask the psychologist to carefully
explain the question to him.
Most of the time, Gruber tried to make irritating,
slow-motion small talk, concerning everything
from the weather to movies he enjoyed.
The interview had been utterly worthless.
Until, four hours in, Gruber mentioned something
that awakened a strange memory in Dr. Whitington.
He said, “Say, Doc, you remember that TV
show, Bobble the Clown?
I loved that show as a kid.
It was like my religion.
Your kid ever watch it?”
There were a number of unsettling things about
this, from the fact that, for some reason,
Dr. Whitington could remember something about
Bobble the Clown, to the fact that Kevin Gruber
had no way of knowing that Dr. Whitington
even had a kid.
But still, he didn’t let his concern show
and instead asked Gruber what he remembered
about Bobble the Clown.
Gruber smiled, and replied: “Bobble taught
me everything I know, Doc.”
To which Dr. Whitington asked the million-dollar
question, “Like what, Kevin?”
Gruber shrugged and said, “All kinds of
stuff, Doc.
Like how to watch without being seen.
How to jimmy open a window without making
a sound.
How to make ‘em hurt real bad without ‘em
dying, see, so you can make it last longer.
So it can be more fun.
And of course, he taught me to get out without
leaving anything behind.
Bobble made all this possible, Doc.
And he told me all about you, too.
That all this was gonna happen someday.
All good things have to come to an end eventually,
right?
Tell the wife and kid he says hi, by the way.”
Dr. Whitington was astounded.
Gruber seemed to stare vacantly off into space
for a moment, before suddenly claiming that
he had a terrible headache, and he needed
to go back to his cell.
In any other situation, Whitington might have
just written off “Bobble the Clown” as
one of two things - A psychotic delusion,
or a sophisticated psychopath faking a psychotic
delusion in hopes of getting the insanity
plea.
Like the Son of Sam Killer, David Berkowitz,
pretending a demonic talking dog possessed
by Satan made him commit all of his murders.
But Whitington had heard of this Bobble the
Clown before, and it wasn’t in a scenario
that a gas station clerk like Kevin Gruber
ever would have heard of.
It took half a day of research into his own
archived notes to remember exactly where he’d
heard it before: A child he’d interviewed
almost a decade ago, who’d shoved gasoline
and fireworks through the letterbox of an
old woman’s home, leading to a fire that
left the woman and her dog dead.
When Dr. Whitington interviewed the crying
child about his motives, he’d said that
it wasn’t his fault; Bobble the Clown had
told him to do it on the TV.
Given that there were no records of a Bobble
the Clown show ever airing on any local networks,
Whitington had written it off at the time
as the overactive imagination of a very frightened,
very disturbed young child.
That same child would later go into psychiatric
care, before reoffending as a serial arsonist
upon release.
The last building he ever burned down had
only one occupant: Himself.
Fire investigators would later state that
he just sat there, legs crossed, placidly
waiting for the flames to lick his bones clean.
It was becoming incredibly clear that this
“Bobble the Clown” fantasy - if it were
even a fantasy at all - seemed to be much
more than an isolated phenomenon.
He used his credentials to start exploring
other strange crimes of passion committed
by children and young adults, even asking
some of his friends in the criminal psychology
community - off the record - if they’d ever
heard of such a concept before.
Frighteningly, it didn’t take Dr. Whitington
very long at all to hit paydirt.
There was the case of the Orfeo Family Murders
in 1985, out in Arkansas.
Nine-year-old Donnie Orfeo had taken his dad’s
rifle out of the cabinet in the dead of night,
and walked room to room, shooting his mother,
father, and two older sisters in their beds.
Neighbors had heard the gunshots and called
the police.
By the time they arrived at the scene, the
only survivor was Donnie Orfeo himself, drenched
in blood, sitting in front of the TV.
His hollow eyes stared, zombie-like, into
the static.
He did not resist arrest.
When Donnie was taken in for questioning,
his emotional responses were cold and flat.
When he was asked why he murdered his family,
he said that it was because his father told
him he was watching too much TV.
His favorite TV character, Bobble the Clown,
had told him that if he murdered his family
with daddy’s gun, he could watch as much
TV as he liked.
Just reading this, Dr. Whitington could feel
sweat beading on his brow.
Two cases were a coincidence, but three were
a pattern.
And oh, how he wished it had stopped at just
three.
From four days of searching, he’d discovered
no fewer than seventeen different seemingly
isolated crimes with mentions of Bobble the
Clown attached to the file.
A five-year-old boy from New Jersey who’d
drowned his neighbors’ cat in a river with
a gym bag full of heavy stones told police
that he’d learned the technique from Bobble
the Clown.
An eight-year-old girl, arrested for tying
up and torturing her sister with a rusty coat
hanger in Texas, had, of course, gotten the
idea from watching an episode of Bobble the
Clown.
Murder.
Assault.
Vandalism.
Torture.
An extensive, country-wide rap sheet all led
back to that one recurring factor: They all
learned it from watching Bobble the Clown.
Dr. Whitington had gotten in contact with
a few friends who knew people in broadcasting.
While carefully omitting some of the grislier
details, he implored them for any new information
on whether a TV show with Bobble the Clown
had ever gone out, anywhere.
But despite their best efforts, they didn’t
find any records of Bobble the Clown or any
similar educational clown shows airing.
Was it possibly some complex shared hallucination?
Dr. Whitington simultaneously felt burdened
by all this terrifying knowledge, and utterly
powerless to do anything useful with it.
If he started blowing the whistle to the media
or his superiors that a spate of horrible
crimes were all being caused by a violent,
imaginary clown, he’d look just as deranged
as any of the people he’d been studying.
There seemed to be nothing he could do to
stop or help any of this.
He returned home that night with a heavy heart,
hanging up his coat.
He needed someone to talk to about all this,
but he couldn’t burden his wife with the
horrors he encountered daily on the job - Much
less a living nightmare like this mysterious
Bobble The Clown.
As he walked towards the kitchen to pour himself
a stiff drink, he heard strange, jaunty music
coming from the living room.
He stepped back, and saw his seven-year-old
son, Ben, watching something on TV.
As he stepped closer, he could scarcely believe
his eyes.
Ben entranced, eyes fixed on a dancing, grinning,
animated clown on the screen.
Ben slowly turned his head towards Dr. Whitington,
eyes wide and bulging, and said, “I’ve
been waiting for you to get home, Daddy.
Bobble says he got tired of playing with Kevin.
He wants to play with us now.”
Dr. Whitington turned and looked at the clown
on the screen again.
He could swear it was smiling right at him.
That was the last thing he remembered before
the sudden intense headache, and the ground
standing up to embrace him.
When he woke up, he was in bed with his wife,
and neither of them could move - Thanks to
the heavy ropes binding their body to the
frame.
Bobble is very good at teaching children to
tie knots.
They tried to scream, but a shiny flash of
duct tape held both of their mouths closed.
Dr. Whitington’s eyes swiveled in his head
to Ben, standing at his bedside.
The boy was holding a kitchen knife, and he
was very eager to show his mom and dad the
fun new trick Bobble the Clown had taught
him.
To the SCP Foundation, this terrifying anomalous
TV show is known as SCP-993 - Known to cause
blackouts in adults and violent, antisocial
behavior in children.
They do their best to keep the broadcasts
contained, but if ever a child in your life
seems to be acting strangely, perhaps ask
yourself very carefully what they’re watching
when you’re not around...
Now go check out “The Secret at the Bottom
of SCP-087 - EXPLAINED” and “Procedure
110 Montauk REVEALED - Fear Alone - SCP-231
Tale” for more harrowing tales of anomalous
terror!